maybe if I hold my breath it won't be
too bad hi it's Michele from lab muffin
beauty science chemistry PhD and tea
addict and today we're going to be
talking about an ingredient that's as
old as fire and it's getting more
popular as the word detox it's activated
charcoal you'll find activated charcoal
in products like face cleansers face
masks toothpaste and even supplements
what is activated charcoal what does it
do and doesn't work here's the science
charcoal is carbon soot that's made from
burning organic matter
usually this is plants but anything
that's biological and carbon-based will
work activated charcoal is charcoal
that's been treated to give it a
sponge-like texture with lots and lots
of holes if you zoom into activated
charcoal it's very jaggedy giving it a
huge surface area some scientists have
estimated that 1 gram of activated
charcoal which is this much
has a surface area of about 3,000 square
meters this is about three Olympic
swimming pools or seven basketball
courts or 230 car park spaces activated
charcoal is used by a lot of
chemical-free kinds of companies so I
thought I'd make a side note to clarify
that
yes charcoal is actually a chemical it's
made of carbon and it's on the periodic
table right here if you also want a
smartass molecule mug to annoy your
coworkers with or if you're looking for
a gift for a friend who won't shut up
about science
check out these lab muffin mugs I have
another video on the myths about natural
versus chemical beauty products which
I'll link in the description so
activated charcoal has this massive
surface area but what's so great about
having so much space if you zoom in two
molecules at a microscopic level you'll
discover that everything is slightly
sticky molecules like to cling onto each
other
that's why water has surface tension and
why particles in solids and liquids
don't spread out and turn into gases
unless you put a lot of heat into them
these sticky forces are called
intermolecular forces which work a
little bit like magnets everything is
kind of a little bit magnetic because
activated charcoal has such a big
surface area that means there's tons of
space for substances to stick to for
example if you have a glass of water
with dye and you stir activate a
charcoal in it once a dye molecule
bashes into a piece of charcoal it's
stuck and it's the same with an orange
fizzy drink the brand of which I'm not
going to say this is massively sped up
because if you've ever tried filtering
anything in real life you know it takes
forever
I look like a footballer or something
tough footballer explains skincare this
stuff smells really nasty it's like
rotten eggs or something I think it's
because I bought the activated charcoal
off eBay which now I know is not
something you should do if you're
intending to drink it it's got a bouquet
of farts so rotten egg gas is hydrogen
sulfide and apparently if you can smell
it it's already a toxic dose so I don't
think I'm going to die per se maybe if I
hold my breath it won't be too bad it
actually tastes okay it's kind of just
sugary water there's not much of an
orange flavour anymore but maybe that's
just covered up by the farts this one's
definitely more sour yeah I think
they're about the same sweetness just
that this is missing all the sour flavor
so it just tastes really bland and
watery most of the fart smell's gone or
maybe my nose has just died now you
might have heard that charcoal works
like a magnet which makes you think that
maybe the charcoal might be able to drag
out dirt from deep inside pores but
that's not actually how it works
activated charcoal needs to basically
bash into the dirt for it to stick it's
more like a big ball covered in glue
rather than a magnet but a big ball
covered in glue isn't really as catchy
as like a magnet so nerve the marketing
teams decided to stick with magnet
so why do people use activated charcoal
for detoxing well in medicine activated
charcoal is only really used for
poisoning cases so this is when you want
to soak up as much stuff as possible
from the stomach and gut so it doesn't
absorb into your body and kill you
instead what you'll do is you end up
pooping out the poison covered charcoal
and you go about the rest of your life
not dead
so since it's a common treatment for
soaking up actual toxins that can kill
you the logic goes something like the
charcoal has some sort of special
attraction for toxins and so if you eat
it normally then it also soaks up the
toxins from your body unfortunately
that's not how it actually works because
science is kind of inconvenient and
sometimes a bit of a dick the thing is
activated charcoal doesn't really have a
brain it's just a sticky sponge and this
sponge can't tell the difference between
a good molecule and a bad molecule it
can't tell us something is a good
nutrient that you want to let absorb
into your body or a poison that you want
to suck out it just soaks it up using
these dispersion forces
which is a type of intermolecular force
activated charcoal has a kind of
intermolecular force that absolutely
everything else can stick to something
called dispersion forces when two
substances come really close together
their electrons move and they stick
together this happens with every type of
substance so at a basic level everything
is very sticky because activated
charcoal has such a huge surface area
because of all the holes in it there's
tons of space for everything to stick to
anything that sticks to charcoal more
strongly than it sticks to water will be
removed by the activated charcoal this
includes toxins but also vitamins and
medications activated charcoal will
stick onto all of these and stop them
from completely going into your body
this means you won't get the full
benefit of the nutrients or your
medications and most of the time this is
not what you want if you've been
poisoned then nutrients are probably not
so important right at that very second
but if you're eating activated charcoal
as part of your regular diet then it
probably isn't making you any healthier
on the other hand in skincare when you
put activated charcoal on your face you
generally don't apply it at the same
time as your beauty products which have
your beneficial ingredients so it isn't
as much of an issue now back to this
idea of it working a bit like a magnet
the problem with this explanation is
that dispersion forces fade out very
quickly as the two substances get
further away from each other as you
might already know if you have magnets
they stick together when they're close
but further apart they don't really feel
each other's attraction dispersion
forces are even weaker than this with
distance they fade out much faster than
magnets and so for activated charcoal to
stick to something and trap it it pretty
much needs to be touching so it's better
to think of activated charcoal as a big
ball covered in glue rather than a
magnet this means it isn't going to draw
out impurities from deep inside your
pores or toxins from your bloodstream or
anything like that
what activated charcoal can potentially
do is help soak up oil and dirt from the
surface of your skin sort of like a clay
mask it might also be able to soak up
some all from your pores as well and so
it could suck this oil up and if this
oil has dirt in it it could draw out
some dirt from your pores better than say
a normal cleanser but how long does the
charcoal need to be on your skin for it
to actually do anything unfortunately
there isn't any data available on this
it's also questionable whether it could
do anything when it's suspended in like
a gloopy mask it won't be able to
collide with the dirt on your skin and
so it might not actually be able to get
rid of it I put two activated charcoal
skin care products into the orange drink
a gel patch and a piece of sheet mask
and waited five minutes you can see that
the orange drink is still the same color
you don't see any of the fading that
happened with the plain activated
charcoal there are other ingredients in
these products that are good for hydrating
your skin but I'm pretty skeptical that
the activated charcoal is actually doing
much because it just isn't able to make
close contact with your skin so
theoretically that's how activated
charcoal could potentially work in skincare
activated charcoal is pretty cheap and
is pretty harmless so I think it's a
pretty good product to try in your skin
but I wouldn't take an activated
charcoal supplement regularly at the
very best it's a waste of money that
could make you constipated at worst it
can stop nutrients and medications from
getting absorbed into your body
have you tried charcoal before what did
you think let me know in the comments if
you have a skincare ingredient or a
skincare product that you want me to
talk about next let me know as well I
try to upload videos every second
Thursday thanks for watching this video
if you liked it I'd really appreciate it
if you subscribe to my channel and also
like my video I also regularly talk
about the science behind beauty products
on my blog and on my Instagram and see
you next time for more beauty science